it is cinco de mayo meaning the
margaritas are going to be flying well
now well if they're flying
hey they should be being
consumed not flying around if you're
celebrating home safely we got some
ideas for you joining us this morning
the good folks over at who songs mexican
cantina home
of the og margarita welcome guys how's
it going
it's good to see you once again yeah so
heidi i love it thanks for coming on the
show and you've got amethyst here
working making the magic yeah she is our
margarita mixologist
but this is really important you know
everybody thinks they know how to make a
margarita but we've all had bad ones
yeah so we don't use mixes we don't use
any of that fake stuff that's the key
right we make a real margarita oh my god
amethyst is our expert and she is going
to make a real margarita okay but a real
one so none of the soda how do we do it
let's learn your magic so we've got our
glass right and our lime juice so we're
going to go ahead and pour an ounce and
a half of lime juice in that glass right
there and that is just lime juice like
you can buy it or you can squeeze the
lime yourself fresh lime juice fresh
squeezed lime juice and then we've got
our triple sec and our agave nectar as
well so we're going to do an ounce of
both of those
right in there nice and generous i like
that you know all right yeah it's the
morning it's okay and then our tequila
ah yes gotta have our tequila that yeah
that's the key right the crucial
ingredient
and then ice and uh etc so we're gonna
dress our glass a little bit make it
look super fancy get that nice salted
rim on there
a nice little decorative trick we're
gonna use this half squeeze of lime and
put that on the bottom
so we're going to take our other cup and
put some ice in this bad boy real quick
i'm just going to use this thing
and this is all i mean you can all be as
as cool as amethyst here and put it all
together we can do it at home and make
our own yeah
let's talk about that well while the
margarita is being finished off here how
jammed are you guys going to be on cinco
de mayo today we are going to be damned
and get there get there early
come on in yeah
you're i mean it's going to be a fun day
we have cool swag
patients we're going to have our rock
and roll mariachis at both locations i
do love that part i love it they're fun
and you say both locations for folks
that don't know there's one in mandalay
bay yes but uh the one that i tend to
frequent uh would be at boca park yes i
focus
we do have ours with an outside patio
and it's gonna be a gorgeous day today
so please come and i'll be there i'll be
at the boca park location all day say hi
to heidi or you could say hi to amazon
people are attending at 12 at the
mandalay bay location so if you want one
made by me i'll actually be there real
quick
wrap up here why don't you give it a
shot here and start your secret to my
office all right cheers all right
cinco de mayo
i have salt all over my face oh my gosh
this is so good i drink the whole thing
all
right
okay all right made specifically for
this getting started early sherry good